le connaissez la suite a eu un
pressentiment
mais tu l'a balayé
dû écouter ton petit pressentiment mais
tout comme je t'écoute en ce moment tu
peuvent parler
je suis ton seul ami maintenant
et pas spécialement bien vu dans le
service
du pas mal changé depuis que vous avez
quitté le service
il faut toujours la trappe et ouais
alors soit pas changé tant que ça
soyez assurés que nous sommes investies
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 pour
résoudre cette affaire ces affaires
c'est un rocker ci s'arrête il m'est
arrivé de me conduire il a sûrement une
bonne caisse peut-être deux pleins de
kilomètres au compteur
elle doit beaucoup vous plaire ma
voiture ouais et le coffre il est
spacieux
je me pose une question comment un type
qui a le meilleur taux d'élucidation peu
travaillé 15 ans en promotion
j'ai pas dû fréquenter le collectif
quand je te regarde dans les yeux ce que
je vois c'est pas bon
[Musique]
mais connaissait tous les détails mais
il était loin du lieu du meurtre
pourquoi tout ça pourquoi tout ça
[Musique]
le coffre il est spacieux
est ce que tu veux je veux coincer ce
pourri pour que pour toutes les filles
qui l'a tué
[Musique]
aussi je veux subissent alors la
différence c'est que fut pour moi
[Musique]
les détails mais
ce sont les détails qui nous déchire ce
sont les détails qui
nous trahissent
vous